good evening tonight we want to start
with something that's really concerned
to so many of us that's the mental
health of our children
thanks for joining us i'm denise valdez
good evening i'm brian loftis as a
parent it's easy to understand why this
year has been so hard on adults let
alone children
it has been specifically tough for
students in 4th
through 12th grades yeah brian and the
numbers really back that up take a look
since distance education started 20
students have committed suicide
tonight 8 news now reporter kristen
drummond shows us how a high school in
the valley
is empowering kids to connect with their
peers and potentially
save lives be that person who smiles
an open conversation about mental health
there are no
guarantees that we won't experience a
suicide at spring valley
roughly 30 students in a virtual meeting
are part of hope squad
a peer-to-peer suicide prevention
program in its first year at spring
valley high school
we're not there to solve problems but
we're there to listen
madison alexander and the others started
their training in september
all chosen by their classmates to be a
part of this group
they meet bi-monthly and learn how to
recognize kids struggling
and offer support i have told some
teachers like oh
this student in your class can you ask
them if they are okay
we don't train hope squad members to be
therapists or counselors
we train them to be friends dr greg
hudnall joining the chat
what we want you to be is the eyes and
ears of the school
he created hope squad more than 15 years
ago in utah
after the former high school principal
identified the body of a student
who had taken his life when i got done i
walked to my car and i literally threw
up and saw
i made a vow that i would do everything
i could to help prevent
suicide making good on his promise more
than 950 schools
nationwide and in canada use the program
spring valley
making the choice before the pandemic to
start hope squad and it's making a
difference as
more students deal with isolation during
distance education
we've already had some success stories
that the advisor has shared with me
focusing on help and giving hope when
students need it most
kristin drummond 8 news now there are
roughly
15 hope squads at ccsd schools according
to hudnall he had
seven out of 10 children experiencing
depressive or suicidal thoughts
will confide in a friend or trusted peer
before
approaching an adult